good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy monday if you
watch donald trump closely over his four
years in office and we did it became
pretty clear that the more outlandish
the claim that trump happened to be
making the more likely it was to be true
trump did tend to exaggerate at times
but was mostly about topics that didn't
matter how big was the crowd at his 2016
inauguration
who cares
but on the big things on matters of
civilizational importance trump told the
truth bluntly often when nobody else
would the iraq war was a mistake trump
said illegal immigration is a disaster
china is taking over the world haiti is
a pretty crappy place
deafening hysteria followed every one of
these demonstrably true statements at
one point in early 2018 cnn and the
washington post got so worked up trying
to hide the obvious that they devoted
blanket coverage to the claim that
actually haiti is an awesome and fully
functional country a perfect spot for
your next family vacation and by the way
if you disagree with that you're racist
that's what they told us
three years later they have dropped the
pose at least on haiti our leaders now
consider haiti so awful that just being
from there qualifies you for asylum in
the united states with trump go on they
can finally admit that what was once a
dangerous conspiracy theory is now just
a sensible observation especially when
it justifies more immigration
for four years no dangerous conspiracy
theory was considered more dangerous or
more conspiratorial than the claim that
hillary clinton's presidential campaign
had spied on donald trump
the very idea that hillary clinton of
all people had spied on anyone was
preposterous the media informed us only
a lunatic would claim otherwise
by making a charge like that in fact
trump was embolding our enemies and
degrading the public's confidence in our
democratic system
so it wasn't just a stupid opinion that
trump had it was really a form of
treason
and yet as usual trump kept saying it
watch him do it again in one of his last
sit-down interviews as president with
leslie stahl of 60 minutes
the biggest scandal was when they spied
on my campaign they spied on my campaign
there's no real evidence of that of
course there is it's all over the place
leslie they spied on my campaign and
they got caught can i say something
you know this is 60 minutes
and we can't put on things we can't
verify put it on because it's bad for
abiding we can't put on things we can't
verify leslie they spied on my campaign
well we can't very well i'm totally
verified no
it's been just go down and get the
papers
they spied on my campaign they got
caught no and then they went much
further than that and they got caught
and you will see that leslie and you
know that but you just don't want to put
it really as a matter of fact i don't
know that
no as a matter of fact we can't verify
that this is cbs news we don't air
things we can't verify
really leslie stahl is that true
we still remember a cbs news piece from
2016 that claimed that donald trump was
secretly working with vladimir putin so
the question is how did cbs news verify
those facts walk us through your
reporting process
well as it turns out that particular
story the reporting came from reading a
piece on slate.com probably while
standing in line at starbucks
slate alleged that the trump campaign
was coordinating with a russian bank
called alphabank using a hidden server
in trump tower how did slate.com know
this by consulting a quote small tightly
knit community of computer scientists
these scientists slade insisted were
totally nonpartisan one of the sources
explained anonymously quote we wanted to
defend both campaigns because we wanted
to preserve the integrity of the
election
so here you have just another unnamed
computer scientist defending election
integrity makes sense don't ask
questions
jake sullivan did not ask questions jake
sullivan takes slate.com very seriously
at the time jake sullivan was working
for the hillary clinton campaign he
cited the slate story as evidence that
trump was indeed colluding with vladimir
putin quote the secret hotline may be
the key to unlocking the mystery of
trump's ties to russia
sullivan said what a tool we can only
assume that federal authorities will now
explore this direct connection between
trump and russia
so there was a bat phone in trump tower
that rang directly in the kremlin
jake sullivan stuck to that line for
months here he is on cnn in march of
2017.
what we learned during the campaign was
that very serious computer science
experts people who work closely uh with
the united states government had
uncovered this secret hotline between uh
the alpha bank the russian bank and the
trump organization now of course we
didn't know for sure if in fact that
were the case but we knew that it should
be investigated and we knew that given
how serious these computer scientists
were they weren't just making up
crackpot theories so it wasn't
surprising to learn that even as of last
week the fbi is still looking into this
and you have any idea what they're what
they're looking for i don't of course i
don't have a line into the fbi on this
but what i know based on public
reporting
is that there is very unusual server
activity between this russian bank and
the trump organization which suggests
contact that took place over the course
of the campaign
oh the secret hotline
these people are
literally willing to say anything if it
gives them power but listen carefully to
what jake sullivan said i don't have a
line into the fbi on this everything i
know is from public reporting
so you'll notice that sullivan went out
of his way to say that
which should have been a very clear sign
that it was a lie and indeed it was a
lie in fact the hillary clinton for
president campaign was coordinating
directly with the fbi a clinton lawyer
called michael sussman had been feeding
false claims about trump and russia once
again from that crack team of
nonpartisan computer scientists
to the general counsel of the fbi a man
called james baker but sussman didn't
stop there in february of 2017 after the
election sussman also met with the
general counsel at cia
so at this point you may be wondering
about the identity of those non-partisan
computer scientists who dug up all this
new information about donald trump's
direct connection to vladimir putin who
are these people
we may not be shocked to learn they
weren't non-partisan once again jake
sullivan was lying to us
in fact a pro-hillary clinton activist
from south africa called rodney jaffe
had put together a team of digital
researchers
oppo guys we used to call them most of
them came from georgia tech in emails
rodney jaffe explained why he was doing
this he wanted hillary to win the
presidency because hillary clinton had
promised him a job as a top cyber
security officer in the u.s government
so jaffe wanted to help hillary win he
said that in order to do that he gave
his non-partisan computer scientists a
mission their job was to gather data
they had access to thanks to a pentagon
contract in order to connect donald
trump to putin
now we know all this thanks to a new
court filing from special counsel john
durham who spent the last few years
investigating the origins of the russia
hoax and is finally producing some
material
in the words of durham's filing quote
jaffe tasked those researchers to mine
internet data to establish an inference
and a narrative tying then-candidate
trump to russia
so this wasn't reporting of course
they had a goal they were trying to get
hillary elected president
the amazing thing is how they did it
where their data came from the filing
says that jaffina's computer scientists
intercepted internet traffic that is
emails and presumably text messages from
quote trump tower donald trump's central
park west apartment building and the
executive office of the president of the
united states
in other words trump was right
this isn't a conspiracy theory his
claims were true democrats were spying
on donald trump not just as a candidate
but as president of the united states in
the white house as well as in his own
home
so has anything like this ever happened
in american history not that we know of
but jeff bezos doesn't think you should
worry about it or even know that it
happened today's washington post
informed its brain-dead readership that
while trump is once again claiming that
he was spied upon
that claim has been quote debunked
oh really how has it been debunked shut
up it just has
but in fact that claim has not been
debunked it has been verified that claim
is true it actually happened and the way
it happened tells you everything about
why it has been so extraordinarily
difficult to bring democracy back to the
united states
a government contractor spied on a
populist presidential candidate then
passed the information to his opponent's
campaign which gave it to the fbi in the
news media which distorted it to create
the illusion of treason which was then
cited by the politician who paid for the
whole thing as a reason not to vote for
the guy she spied on
got it it's a closed loop
everyone's got a role
here's hillary clinton during the
presidential debates
from everything i see has no respect for
this
person well that's because he'd rather
have a puppet as president no pop state
it's pretty clear
it's pretty clear you won't admit
the russians have engaged in cyber
attacks against the united states of
america that you encouraged
espionage against our people that you
are willing to spout the putin line sign
up for his wish list break up nato do
whatever he wants to do and that you
continue to
get help from him because he has a very
clear favorite in this race
so if you're not all in with nato if you
think it's a pointless boondoggle that
endangers the united states you my
friend work for vladimir putin you
encouraged espionage shrieked hillary at
the very moment she was doing precisely
that they always denounce you for their
own sins but she said russia has engaged
in cyber attacks on the united states
and that's probably true in point of
fact but she was speaking about a
specific quote cyber attack
she was talking about the russians
hacking the servers at the dnc
democrats wasted three years of our
lives telling us that at ever increasing
volume here's the interesting thing it
was not true it has never been true
vladimir putin did not hack the dnc
there was never any evidence that the
russians hacked the dnc instead the dnc
emails were very clearly stolen from
within the building
most likely by a bernie sanders
supporter who wanted to show the world
how bernie sanders was being shafted by
the very same corrupt forces in
washington that later shafted donald
trump
that was very obvious to anyone who was
paying attention at the time
what's interesting is that no one's been
punished for it likely no one ever will
be in fact jake sullivan the guy you
just saw lying about those nonpartisan
computer scientists has not been
indicted for what he did jake sullivan
has been promoted jake sullivan is now
joe biden's national security adviser
he's still screaming about russia only
this time it's not to bring down a
republican opponent in a presidential
race he's screaming about russia to
bring the entire country to war with the
nuclear armed power hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else